for a bottle of vodka vodka there's
really only one way to clean it with
more vodka it's made on local
ingredients and we make a really good
vodka here in in downtown Berlin but
it's not all so innocent in a bid for
local street cred the world's
second-biggest distiller penola cod
converted this old garage and finance
the project and they came up with the
idea to build micro distilleries around
the world and have local people running
them this beaker of vodka is the
finished product before it gets bottled
it needs to be tested for both taste and
alcohol content some drinkers have a
vodka problem but vodka has a drinkers
problem they're not enough of them which
is why distilleries like this one small
batch they're trying to reverse that
trend it's not quite bathtub vodka but
it's operators know the local market we
provide the water and and the ethanol we
don't use pen arica a sales channels we
are completely responsible on how to
sell ourselves the contribution from /
know the recipe the yeast for the
so-called aromatic fraction
to break even they need to sell about
six thousand bottles suggested retail 13
euros and this vodka is the newest
addition to Berlin's drink scene yeah
but that's right that's drinkable at
room temperature there go good [ __ ] Hans
Nichols Bloomberg Berlin